tonight on the new reality I do have my
days where I'm like terrified that
someone I love will get sick the echo
pandemic of mental illness we know that
it's not just a secondary wave it's
actually happening right now the future
of travel health checks are here to stay
just like after 9/11 the travel
experience will be changed forever
optimism from a Canadian billionaire we
got a big bump in the road here but
we'll get through it and on and the
things won't be fine
deliver us from evil and hoping that
people who use these apps begin to
realize how it affects the restaurants
they think they're supporting and
keeping the faith we're learning to do
ministry in a completely different way
[Music]
hello I'm Donna Friesen we're all
finding ways to cope in this new reality
getting accustomed to living a
physically distant existence but there's
nothing normal about this silence and
emptiness where there's usually hustle
and bustle it's disconcerting social
distancing is not what cities are
designed for and it's not what most
humans are wired for we've shut down so
much to keep kovat 19 from spreading
because this is a physical health crisis
but there's something deeper going on
inside us
it's sowing the seeds of a major mental
health crisis whether it's grief over a
loved ones death fear of getting sick
anxiety over losing your job and not
being able to pay the bills
psychological distress is widespread and
the stresses have multiplied especially
for those dealing with mental illness
before the pandemic hit abigail Beaman
explores the impact dealing with a
pandemic is an extra challenge for
Christina Dell korpal the Montreal woman
has general anxiety disorder because
we're all going through this giant
traumatic experience it's definitely
easier for me to get set off and like to
start panicking so that's why I have to
be like extra vigilant and pay attention
to my emotions
but after the year she's had that's not
easy struggles with infertility her
father had a stroke and then Dell corpo
planned to start her own design and
digital marketing business excited for a
new challenge she quit her job in
January right before the world shut down
there's some of these were like just
terrified that you know someone I love
will get sick or maybe we're gonna lose
our condo or you know I won't be able to
find a job after all of this is over
because there's so many other Canadians
that are like without jobs Dell Corp oh
no she's not alone Health Canada tells
global news 11 million Canadians will
show high levels of stress in family and
work settings and 2 million will show
signs of traumatic stress projections
based in part on the aftermath of SARS
where more than 40% of Canadians
suffered from increased stress levels
but by the time this pandemic is over
numbers could climb even higher separate
polling by both if Sousa and Angus Reid
show half of Canadians feel their mental
health has already worsened we know that
it's not it's not just a secondary wave
it's actually happening right now our
service volume has doubled for young
people who are reaching out for support
an increase of about 50% more calls than
we were receiving this time last year
two examples from organizations on the
front lines typically what we would see
a social isolation increased concerns
around mental health or symptoms that
they're experiencing and what we're
seeing with kovat is an increase in all
of those things that they've been
somehow amplified it's also meant a
change in how mental health workers
provide that desperately needed support
Toronto's Gerstein Center was forced to
close their short-term beds and park
their mobile crisis van now they're
focused on calls and wellness check
outreach but it's not the same as soon
as we can get back to face to face the
better these staff take calls for 12
hours a day and in a pandemic that can
feel endless the mental health of
frontline workers is also a concern
there's still this lingering concern of
going into work and working in close
contact with people and potentially
contacting iris Courtney Jackson just
launched the front lines a publication
on medium encouraging other workers to
share their stories she's a mental
health case manager at a residential
care facility in Ontario burnout is a
real problem
so is isolation with many health care
workers self isolating from loved ones
within their own homes mean working in
the mental health fields you expect to
deal with stress and change it's it's
part of the job but the difference is
that right now I'm working with people
who have a limited understanding of the
situation they feel powerless to the
situation but I myself also feel that
way so in a country that saw long wait
times for mental health services before
the pandemic struck what's being done to
help
health care is a provincial
responsibility and a number of provinces
have stepped up with new programs and
millions in new funding help is
available Alberta is leading the way
after a government survey found 74
percent of Albertans feel their mental
health has been hit by kovat 19 the 53
million dollar additional investment
that we're announcing today is more than
all of the other provinces but what's
being done at the federal level the
Prime Minister keeps promising all kinds
of help but the fact is there's no clear
number on new mental health dollars
coming from Ottawa as the funding is
tied to other things this month the
Prime Minister committed two hundred and
forty million dollars to boost access to
virtual care including mental health and
25 million of that is going to the new
wellness together portal connecting
Canadians with free help including phone
text and video counseling there will be
more to do and we know that this this
secondary pandemic if you will is just
as in many ways as a matter fact I would
say it's just as urgent as this one in
its first three weeks more than a
hundred and fifty thousand Canadians
used the portal help is offered via a
number of partner agencies not
government employees after eight
thousand volunteers answered a call from
kids help phone now the service known
for helping kids is responsible for all
the texts that come through the portal
anybody that texts whether they're a
youth or they're an adult will text 24/7
and reach one of our trained volunteer
crisis responders and those are
volunteers that go through a rigorous
training process and they're overseen in
real time by paid professional staff but
the site does ask you to provide your
name and email the agency overseeing it
says there is help available without
registering and the data is only visible
to the person submitting it designed to
be like a Fitbit people are able to see
their progress so that's the Peter
Cornish says they're working on a way to
make registration optional as they brace
for increased demand over the next few
months he says as it
elipse peer mentorship will become more
important so that everyone can support
each other better which is why we came
up with the name wellness together
Canada Cristina Dell corpo is managing
pretty well these days and she wants to
help others too so she's been blogging
you didn't always feel this stressed out
this bad and it's gonna pass and just
keep that in mind and keep pushing for
it and if you really need help reach out
to someone the battlecry of this
pandemic has been we're all in this
together or put another way you're not
alone their focus is on caring for
others so their own mental health takes
a backseat later on the new reality we
meet an emergency room physician
documenting her colleagues at work
hoping to create a permanent record of
their sacrifice I don't think that we're
used to talking about our own needs so
us being afraid or feeling vulnerable or
us needing the time and the self
compassion that's not something that we
easily asked for because we're there to
help them and at the same time we feel
very vulnerable ourselves and that's
very hard to talk about the Victoria Day
long weekend is usually the unofficial
start of summer but something feels a
bit glum this year summer vacation plans
are either canceled or in limbo unless
you are planning to stick close to home
because that's where most of us will be
and it's those poll conducted
exclusively for global news found even
if they were allowed only 20% of
Canadians surveyed said they'd likely
travel outside the country in 2020 50
percent said they likely wouldn't
slightly more people are open to
domestic travel 37 percent said they'd
venture beyond their home province
Travel is at a standstill few industries
have fallen as far as fast and when it
does recover things will look a lot
different
Jackson prosecco explains over the years
Canadians Bob and Dorothy Grubb have
taken more than a dozen cruisers their
last trip sailed right into a global
health crisis in March they were on
board the Grand Princess trapped off the
coast of California as a mysterious
virus spread through the passengers and
crew they first noticed something wasn't
right when their favorite waiter wasn't
at dinner
one evening he just wasn't there and
asked what happened oh he's off sick
okay so the next day he is back and I
said Oh exam you're good to see you back
I said but you look tired said I'm okay
the next day Xavier isn't there
he's lost sick again soon the US Coast
Guard was airlifting coded 19 test kits
to the boat the grubs were confined to
their cabin waiting for a plan to get
off the ship and get home to British
Columbia without getting sick after our
cabins meals placed at our door with a
knock on the door and
that was the end of any contact with
people those were the first days of the
pandemic before every cruise ship
stopped sailing before air travel
dropped of staggering 95 percent before
the Las Vegas Strip sat empty it's safe
to say travelers and the travel industry
have never seen anything like this
so my last flight was on March 1st and I
can't remember a time I've gone this
long without being in the sky Brian
Kelly is better known as the points guy
as founder of the travel website he
warns this shock to the system will lead
to immediate and permanent changes to
the way we travel should you expect that
when you check into a hotel or get on a
plane that someone's going to be taking
your temperature health checks are here
to stay just like after 9/11 lengthy
airport checks were implemented the same
will be happening and is happening in
the airline space right now emirates is
actually doing instant koban tests and
Etihad has temperature checks on their
check-in kiosks and those are just a
couple of the ways that the travel
experience will be changed forever
Air Canada will be the first airline in
North America to do temperature checks
on every passenger not just to stop
travelers from infecting each other but
because the public is nervous very
nervous about getting back out there I
hope they don't think that things are
going to be exactly as they were prior
to Kovan 19 Lori Pennington grey is a
professor in the department of tourism
at the University of Florida the school
publishes a travel anxiety index it
shows fear and worry about travel have
increased a whopping 311 percent from
pre coronavirus days do people even want
to travel right now the majority of the
research is saying that there's still
you know some pent up demand but that
they're gonna wait six months or so
before they start to think about their
travel and a lot of that has to do with
this understanding of what the industry
is going to do to keep them safe
long before kovat 19 supermodel Naomi
Campbell documented her own airplane
disinfection routine back then it seemed
over-the-top I do not care
nobody's laughing now at American
Airlines caring for you is our priority
airlines have come to realize that deep
cleaning is a must so are masks for
flight attendants and passengers a
company called germ Falcon is developing
equipment to disinfect the entire cabin
between flights using ultraviolet light
major hotel chains are partnering with
name-brand disinfectant manufacturers
expect big changes when cruise ships
finally do return to the sea and so the
research also suggests that more than
60% expects that the industry is going
to have to provide you know PPE for the
visitors at touch points throughout the
travel experience and that there's more
than 70 percent that say that there's an
expectation that they're going to share
what they're doing with the visitor as
far as keeping that visitor safe there's
one basic problem the industry can't
overcome social distancing it's hard to
do in a hotel lobby or on board a cruise
ship and virtually impossible on a plane
train or bus that hasn't stopped the
rush to return to the high seas Carnival
Cruises aims to sail again in August
they've seen a remarkable surgeon
bookings for those first few trips
mostly from young people who in fact are
eager to travel of course the pandemic
may change those plans there's still a
chance those first sailings could be
called off I think the biggest
calculation is going to have to be how
many people am I going to to be around
and expose myself to and be exposed by
them in in in in various settings and
what are the current recommendations and
and why
I one of my comfortable whiz some
airlines have tried to space out
passengers by leaving middle seats open
but they can't do that forever empty
seats don't make money and the airlines
are in dire straits Delta is losing 60
million dollars a day
Air Canada lost more than 1 billion
dollars in the first quarter carriers
are sending hundreds of older planes to
the scrapyard anticipating demand will
take years to return to what it was
most have said they'll emerge smaller
some likely won't survive even with
government bailouts
unfortunately the industry will
consolidate the weak airlines especially
budget airlines will not have the funds
to compete with the majors so the
airline industry has never seen a
challenge like this and they've got a
long road to recovery since business
travel and leisure travel are both off a
cliff those problems are cascading
through an industry that's responsible
for one in 10 jobs worldwide it is
across the board because their
connectivity and the dependency for all
these industries within this sector is
significant what we call the domino
effect in in this case like if one
airline is being impacted then you have
of course a traveler just in the tour
operators their hotels no one is
expecting a quick rebound in the short
term there aren't many places to travel
to not with borders closed and not with
many countries implementing mandatory
quarantine on arrival nobody is going to
spend two weeks vacation in forced
isolation longer term businesses may
decide travel is just not worth the risk
and when it comes time to relax more of
us may opt to stick close to home 2020
may be the year of the road trip back in
BC the Grubbs future vacation plans
definitely look different no flights and
no cruises not now and probably not
anytime soon unless we can see a vaccine
that's going to work
cleanliness stepped up on the ships
we wouldn't be touring which is not
willing to take that risk we wouldn't be
going we've made the decision we're not
going on a cruise period that's end the
story too risky too risky the new
reality will include a new landscape for
business not all companies will survive
this pandemic some have already been
driven into bankruptcy others are on the
brink it is life and death for some
sectors so we asked one of Canada's
best-known and most successful
businessmen for his take on the impact
of this pandemic Jimmy Patterson didn't
inherit money he made it
the billionaire from BC rose from humble
beginnings selling garden seeds
door-to-door and at age 91 remains one
of the world's most successful
entrepreneurs I had the best parents you
could ever get but the only thing we
didn't have was money but that didn't
affect anything his work ethic is
notorious he's delivered newspapers
worked on trains washed cars and always
dreamed big the first business he bought
was a car dealership in Vancouver and
he's never let his foot off the gas the
Jim Patterson group is the second
largest privately held company in Canada
and it's into everything cars signs
agricultural equipment grocery stores
wine stores radio stations forest
products fishing real estate theme parks
and even the Guinness Book of World
Records operation about 48,000 employees
more than 10 billion dollars in annual
sales I have fun going to work every day
everybody's different I just prefer
going to work I like what I do and so I
just keep doing it he shares his wealth
has given millions to BC hospitals
including 75 million to build a new
hospital in Vancouver the largest
donation from a private citizen to a
single medical facility in Canadian
history I got to get up and pay for all
this stuff
no I do have to go to work mr. Patterson
thank you so much for talking to us have
you ever seen a storm like this never
ever seen anything like it
nor has anybody else you know there are
some people who say like Bill Gates for
example who sort of warned about
something like this happening did you
see it coming did you were you able to
put anything in place in your companies
to sort of weather the storm of it
absolutely none blindsided like
everybody else well we certainly never
imagined anything as as deep as this in
the change of the way we get up in the
morning and think about things when it
gets back to whatever is the new normal
which will will take some time there's a
lot of lot of smart people out there and
long term I'm optimistic I think a lot
of people would be surprised to hear how
optimistic you are that things will be
okay when this things will be okay where
does that sense come from is because I
know you've been in business for well
look at decades listen we've been
through Wars depressions diseases
ever since time began and and we wind up
we've never had Moore's education we've
never had more scientific look at all
those wonderful things people like Bill
Gates has accomplished and what he's
done people that today we've never had
as much knowledge as we have in the
world today and opportunity and so we're
going out a big bump in the road here
but we'll get through it and on and the
things will be fine
you know you have so many different
divisions in your company is that been
part of the secret to resilience is
diversity your strength when you have
Isis today yeah
we are diversified
it's been very useful to be diversified
in a situation like this for us
we have businesses doing very very well
and we have others are doing very very
bad but we'll be doing things
differently then we have so what do you
mean by that
how do you see that playing out how you
will do things differently well it
depends on the industry I mean so and
the location certainly if you're in
Quebec it's different than if you're in
Saskatchewan and and it depends what
industry if you're in the food business
is very different than if you're in the
lumber business yeah so take maybe the
food business how do you think do you
think we'll continue to operate in
grocery stores the way we are now or we
will theirs
that'll be it'll it'll change the
grocery stores are different today than
they were 25 years ago so there's always
changed yeah yeah this is going to speed
up some of it you know there's some
people who think including public health
officers that the United States is our
biggest risk right now our proximity to
the US do you have views on when you
think the canada-us border should open
no I don't from a business point of view
the quicker the better
but it may not be the best for the
population let me ask you about your own
health I mean you're in the category of
most risk right now for Kovan 19 I am
does it worry you no no but I I'm
following the rules the best I can
mm-hmm what do you think the biggest
lesson business will learn from this I
think it depends on what kind of
business you're in but I think it's
important to be more conservative than
more aggressive and the approaches you
take to do the the risk probably I'm
using the wrong words here but I think
that that when something like this that
have
that nobody's ever seen anything like it
before that when people start to talk
about that that are experts
it pays probably people like me or
anybody else to pay a lot more attention
to the experts or people that understand
these kinds of things better than then
normally you would my lesson I guess in
life that I keep learning over and over
is listen to the people that Nora but
know more about what's going on than
what you think you do or I do well
that's a lot of humility right not
everyone has that well I'm just telling
you a scenario I said I'm giving you the
answer humility it's a good thing to
have coming up prayer in isolation
that's been a lot to partake but also
some remarkable gifts as well people of
faith adapting how they worship and
deliver us from evil those are the only
customers left now as just prolongs it's
going to be critical for our survival to
be able to make some money why some
restaurants say delivery apps are
hurting their business
you
remember when you'd be friends for
dinner at a restaurant or get together
for drinks at a bar it feels like a
distant memory and the pain is most
acute for all the owners and the
employees of the thousands of
establishments that are shut down many
may never open again in Canada the food
service sector is a ninety three billion
dollar industry it employs 1.2 million
workers in normal times 22 million
customers are served across this country
every day when they are allowed to
reopen it won't be the same for
restaurants and bars physical distancing
will limit the number of customers in
the meantime takeout and delivery is the
only option and as Sean O'Shay reports
food delivery apps are taking a big bite
out of the bottom line until March was
the best year ever our sales went up our
course went down we were expecting that
hey this is the year that we're gonna
make it 2020 is gonna be our year that
is not the case the new decades started
with great expectations in the same way
for us Arafat took a risk leaving a
secure job in opening this 80 seat
restaurant four years ago page one was
named for his fresh start his new
chapter it was and still is an
entrepreneurs dream manual typewriters
provide the atmosphere rating machines
from an earlier era this is a place
where students and creative types would
normally sit and work sometimes linger
for hours sipping coffee and indulging
in sweets then suddenly everything
changed but now it's a different game
there's no customers to attract and we
don't know how are we gonna be able to
maintain enough revenues to support all
the course and keeps up an entire
industry is now asking the same question
from one week to the next
as the Cova 19 pandemic persists
restaurant owners are contemplating how
to stay in business and are wondering
what their business will actually look
like once they're eventually allowed to
reopen for a time at least there will
certainly be fewer seats and tables this
in a business where traditionally
consumers covet a crowd
it's far from ideal you've got a 40 seat
restaurant or bar that sometimes you
want to you know you want to have 50
people in that room in order to create
the experience and so things are going
to be profoundly different and no matter
what happens there's going to be
casualties
casualties no one could have predicted a
year ago May 2019 before the term
physical distancing would become part of
our lexicon Toronto Raptors fans were
engrossed in a playoff run one that
captured the imagination of an entire
Hoop hungry nation fans never expected
much space of their own as they crowded
in and stood glued to watch a big screen
in bars customers were grateful just to
get in the door in the hope of
witnessing history now over a short but
agonizing few weeks coffee shops
restaurants and bars have closed some
for good others say they'll be back the
rest struggled to remain open serving
takeout and delivery customers now as
just prolongs it's going to be critical
for our survival to be able to make some
money making some money means relying on
delivery apps names like doordash and
skip the dishes you've done it by
ordering from local restaurants in their
time of need
among all names in the food delivery
business the behemoth is uber eats every
time I make an uber delivery I lose
money that's right
Restaurant Group executive Nick DiDonato
says he's actually losing money selling
more food
uber eats is now in a position to
dictate almost what restaurants may
survive and may not Hoover eats charges
restaurants the highest commissions in
the industry even though the company
tells consumers that they won't have to
pay to have their food delivered right
now uber is not charging a customer who
calls in for a delivery but they are
charging a restaurant 30% commission
that's the price restaurants pay to uber
when a customer places a delivery order
other apps like doordash and skip the
dishes charge somewhat less and during
the pandemic competitors have made
concessions doordash have looked at the
situation that this is not business as
normal for restaurants and I've actually
cut the rates in half uber has done
absolutely nothing for their restaurant
work the only thing we're doing most
restaurants are doing if anything at all
is takeout and delivery
restaurants prepare to criticize uber
publicly say the company is skimming too
much off the top something that might be
considered improper in normal times but
much worse now but I'm hoping that
people who use these apps begin to
realize how it affects the restaurants
they think they're supporting because
it's not helping the restaurants it's
hurting restaurants right now many
restaurants say for every hundred
dollars spent on a delivery order they
calculate the food cost at thirty or
thirty two dollars the cost of labor to
prepare the food perhaps another thirty
two dollars then ubers cut another
thirty dollars added up and some
restaurants say the formula doesn't
leave much behind for the restaurant
owner the average restaurant in Canada
makes approximately four percent to the
bottom line to make matters worse this
Toronto restaurant for the location in
Vancouver didn't get paid by uber until
seven weeks after the pandemic started
it resorted to Instagram to shame the
company to paying its bill which it
finally did the fact is many restaurants
are afraid to break ties with uber
completely and risk losing the clients
they have who use the app I do need to
get the convenience for those customers
because those are the only customers
left
we asked uber for an interview and
received a statement instead it read in
part Commission's restaurants pay to
overeats for our services is not profit
it goes on Commission's are used to
cover the operating costs of providing
safe reliable services the solution
either needs to be a completely new one
which would potentially involve
restaurants getting together as a group
and potentially organizing their own
system which would include technology
and of course personnel to be the
drivers themselves some restaurant
owners have put uber out of their lives
entirely because it was costing them
just too much that's not sustainable
can't do that Global News viewers have
met the owners of Toronto's fat Lam
cuisine a-- before
now the Greek restaurant partners Vera
and Chris have severed their ties with
ubereats for good and we haven't been
happier Vera and Chris have redesigned
how they serve takeout and delivery as a
result now the restaurant insists on
getting an order a day in advance to
prepare meals mostly for larger groups
who
family Sal fair and when the meals are
cooked and ready Chris and Veera deliver
the food themselves at least for now the
result satisfied customers plus they're
keeping more money in the process which
is key for restaurant owners were about
to lose more than half of their capacity
because of health rules he expected that
we will kill at least 60% of the tables
from wolf them and the seats that's why
I'm motivated for us our effect will do
whatever he can to eke out survival in
the post pandemic food world if that
means you want your coffee and pastry
delivered directly that's no problem but
don't use that third party app message
us or text us we are happy to go and
deliver for them or get the order ready
that will save us a lot on the fees that
we have to pay coming up do I feel
comfortable with the word healthcare
heroes pictures from the heart
storytelling for me is the most powerful
tool that we have for connection and
healing the ER doctor keeping a visual
record of this unprecedented time
dr. Don limbs job is emergency medicine
she's on the front line treating
patients with kovat 19 but there's
another layer to what she does after a
shift or on her days off she picks up
her camera and turns it on her
colleagues capturing what few of us see
the care the precision and the
unpredictability of what it takes to
save lives dr. Lim wants to create a
permanent record of how this pandemic
plays out she's shared her photographs
with us my name is dr. Don Lim I'm an
emergency physician at the University
Health Network which is Toronto General
Hospital and Toronto Western Hospital
I thought his porn hat was five and my
daughter is 16 months now so every time
I say goodbye I close the door my son's
always waiting for me with my daughter
and my husband he bangs on the window
and he says goodbye he makes a little
heart with his index finger and his
thumb and he can't he tries to shout I
love you mom and goodbye and but that's
what he means when he says that to make
sure that I'm brave and as soon as I get
back everything comes off and goes
straight into the wash and I don't I
don't hug my kids I don't say even hello
to them until I've had a really long
shower when the fear of the pandemic and
the unknown started that's when we
started actually talking to our
colleagues who had gone through SARS and
what was that like and one of them told
me that it was very hard for her team
because afterwards when you know the
last patient was cured and they lifted
the restrictions it wasn't something
that they talked about and so I felt
that I felt like this story couldn't be
forgotten the same way that Starr's was
forgotten because we wanted to make sure
that each person with Cova door
suspected ko Ovid had the minimal
exposure to team members the hospital
actually created a team called the code
Delta team which is an intubation team
staffed by
and anesthesia assistant a nurse and a
staff and ISA tests they're checking
their equipment they're making sure they
have all their medications and they're
making sure that they're completely
covered and safe for the intubation I
felt at the very beginning I thought
maybe it was a crazy idea to try to
document the pandemic because I thought
maybe people wouldn't be receptive when
I brought up this idea that people were
very supportive of it and they knew that
if we didn't talk about it then the
story would be forgotten just like SARS
the patient is about to be intubated
it's very challenging
so they decompensate very quickly so you
pretty much have one shot to get the
intubation before they go get into
trouble and the person who's doing the
intubation really wants to minimize any
type of procedure that will increase
aerosolization so it's a first shot one
shot do it right
usually we are used to dealing with
patients who are very sick that's not
new but patients with kovat they they
look well until they don't look well and
that's been very scary visitors aren't
allowed and so when we do have patients
who died not being able to close that
circle and have the family nearby
has been really tough for the team so
she's got the baby monitor in her hand
and she's looking very carefully to see
what the team needs so if you imagine
the face shields and the face mask it's
very hard to hear people and you've also
got the wall of clothes only a few can
stay inside and everyone's on the
outside and everyone's waiting to see
what's going to happen and waiting to
make sure that the team inside has
everything that they need he and his
team are responsible for making sure
that the room is meticulously cleaned
after each patient and you see that he's
he's doing a lot of work to do to keep a
keep to keep the whole team safe we
really appreciate them a lot of the
pictures of people's eyes are so focused
and you see such a concentration
but I do see a strain on people people's
faces and I do see the uncertainty in
their eyes because we're there to help
them and at the same time we feel very
vulnerable ourselves and that's very
hard to talk about I think it's very
common for healthcare providers to not
feel that they necessarily can ask for
help or if they do need help there's a
stigma associated with that sometimes
and this is the the pause that our teams
do at the time of death to pay respects
to the patient that pre kovat it it was
quite common to have the family members
nearby but this patient had only the
medical team to say goodbye so you know
looking at this I think this was a very
special moment for this team as well
because they they knew that what they
had they tried to do everything they
could and still they lost the patient so
it's the time of death so a very moving
photo for the team as well
storytelling for me is the most powerful
tool that we have for connection and
healing but I hope that by doing this
photo essay people remember that feeling
that they had when we came together as a
team that's what I hope that they take a
look from it because I think that's the
power of art it gives us permission to
pause and reflect
next on the new reality praying during a
pandemic we've reached out from two more
communities than ever before how
technology has been a blessing for the
world's faithful millions of people gain
strength and find solace take comfort in
the sense of community that faith and
religious ceremony can provide
it's what so many rely on especially in
times of crisis
now with churches mosques and temples
close the way we come together to pray
to grieve to celebrate new life has had
to change faith is a long game and as
Redman Shannon explains religions all
over the world are learning new lessons
on how to cope
[Music]
social distancing at the western wall
[Music]
face guards in the Far East and honking
for Jesus in the us-south the covert 19
pandemic has changed how we worship
gathering together is a fundamental part
of prayer millions possibly billions of
worshippers have had to modify or
totally suspend congregating some have
resisted orders trusting God before
government but most have bowed down for
the greater good mechas grand mosque has
been almost deserted for Ramadan this
year everybody across the world where
we're normally used to it being a very
community spirited month we're having to
adapt to stay at home rukmi Ahmed works
with a UK charity that normally arranges
huge gatherings welcoming Muslims and
non-muslims to celebrate her two giant
iftar events breaking the daily fast but
this year it's all moved online so where
we would have our normal open estar
events we've essentially just taken that
virtually and this is operated on zoom
and ball cast on our face but livestream
channels as well one thing that we've
actually found is that we've reached out
from to more communities than ever
before so we've had people from
Australia join our Iftars
Iman as Beck's on America a different
faith on a different continent but the
same sense of generosity volunteers at
this Sikh temple in Surrey BC are
delivering thousands of meals to those
who are isolated and to frontline
workers the grid Juarez doors have been
open to only 50 people a day a
restriction that affects more than just
prayer it's also actually a social
activities in
in this in the temples people older
pupils comes for the social activities
and they meet each other you know so is
everything is stopped so the elder
people's they have a very difficult time
as mani worship from home staff prepare
for new measures in the new normal
praying by appointment in shifts if
people some more people wants to come we
will make that for shifts to be can make
the five shifts technology has truly
been a blessing for believers of all
faiths this pandemic would have been
very different just a decade ago but
Skype worship isn't quite possible for
everyone particularly for Orthodox Jews
on the Sabbath we don't operate the you
just don't use our iPhones me don't
operate electricity everything is
prepared in advance we don't travel in
the cards Rabbi David Rosen says some
people have gathered online before
Shabbat others just do the best they can
by my parkin about 15 of us meeting they
keeping social distance seeing how to
eat it
and Mary masks and being able to pray
together luckily enough in a part of the
world that the climate enables us to be
able to do that people often look to
places of worship during epidemics in
hope and in sorrow this church saw the
worst horrors of the Great Plague of
London in 1665 one that killed a fifth
of the city's population
Reverend cannon Allison Joyce has led a
special candle every day since the
church was forced to close she is
inspired by her predecessor Richard
Pearson from 355 years ago I can't help
wondering how what kept him going what
kept him going when it was day after day
after day of that kind of unremitting
tragedy he buries whole families he
buries his congregation members he
buries people whose names he doesn't
know they just found the body and
somehow he kept going no
kovat 19 sermons are broadcast online
featuring mp3 readings from worshipers
at home do not let your hearts be
troubled the church has even created a
kid's newsletter to replace Sunday
school this week's had a whole feature
on my cat can enjoy says difficult
decisions lie ahead when the church
reopens particularly when it comes to
administering Holy Communion there's
been a lot of heartache but also some
remarkable gifts as well I think we're
learning to do ministry in a completely
different way and we're learning lessons
that like many churches will take
forward into the future as well I mean
it's been a time of great opportunity
precisely because we've had to rethink
everything that we do
that's our program for this week you can
find more on tonight's stories on our
website Global News CA / the new reality
and you can catch up on previous
programs you may have missed and read
more about what our new reality might
look like we leave you with a bit of
hope about the future it's a song
written and performed by Joni DeLaurier
she's an award-winning singer-songwriter
who also works at the city of Calgary's
Emergency Operations Center she calls
this song a love letter to her city but
there's a message in it for all of us
[Music]
just like it's always been we'll get it
back again we're gonna
[Music]
coming up next Sunday you will take the
scooter through the downtown the
Canadian city with a hopeful message for
us all just like it's always been